دا بال اللواء فايز الدويري الان نحن في
لحظه
فاصله كل ما قيل عن الهدنه هي تسريبات من
هنا وهناك ولكن لا احد يدري موعدها هل هل
تعتقد فعلا انها قد تتم الليله يعني من
المتوقع ان تتم الليله لانه الاوراق
الضاغطه على الجانب الاسرائيلي اعتقد من
من منظور عسكري على الاقل بدات تكلها يعني
بالامس لم يكن هناك الضوء الاخ لكن جاء
الضوء الاخضر بعد ما تم نشر فيديوهات
عن وضحت حجم الخسائر وثم جاءت كلمه ابو
عبيده عندما تحدث صراحه واشار الى الموضوع
الاسرى وقال ان حكومتكم هي من لا هي من
تعيق العمل لاطلاق سراحهم وبالتالي كانه
وضع الكره في ملعب نتنياهو مباشره فبعدها
مباشره
صدر تصريح او بيان اوضح فيه انه اعطى
الضوء الاخضر الان هو يتحدث بانه متفائل
جاء في هذا اليوم نشر فيديو اخر عما جرى
في جحر الديك وا الرشق الصاروخيه على تل
ابيب وهذه كانت اعتقد تاتي في وقت متزامن
مع الاجتماع المجلس الوزار المصغر او
مجموعه الحرب او فريق الحرب وقد يكون
الاجتماع الموسع عقد ام لم يعقد لم ياتينا
اي خبر وبالتالي هي كمان ورقه ضغط في
البعد العسكري بانه انا ازال قادر على
استمرار القتال متمكن من اداره المعركه
اذا كنت تراهن على هزيمتي وانقاذ الاسرى
بمقاربات فتقدم ل نوقع على اتفاق يضمن
اطلاق اسرى من جانبنا ضمن معادله قد يفصح
عنها لاحقا مقابل اسرى من النساء والاطفال
من جانبكم يضاف الها عمليه ايقاف اطلاق
النار كما تسرب لست ساعات غارات
او ادخال الوقود او ادخال المساعدات وغير
ذلك اذا هي كانه ورقه ضغط واعتقد انه س
يعني لا استطيع ان اجزم يقينا لنقول 45%
لضد و 55% مع هكذا اقرا ان لم اكن مختر
نعم